schon die ausbrüche der sonne sind
wirklich extrem doch diese beobachtung
eines italienischen astronomie teams top
wirklich alles mit hilfe des chandra
röntgenteleskop haben die fachleute
nämlich einen gigantischen massenauswurf
bei einem fremden stern beobachtet eine
echte weltpremiere bei diesem strahlend
ausbruch wird nicht nur millionen grad
heißes plasma ins all geschleudert auch
die masse das aus geschleuderten
materials ist bei dieser gewaltigen
eruption rekordverdächtig klicks und
science fiction täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann und nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
eruptionen auf der sonne sind wirklich
nicht selten dennoch wissen fachleute
noch relativ wenig über diese
spektakulären ereignisse klar ist
bislang bei diesen gigantischen
eruptionen wird plasma ins all
geschleudert dabei wird besonders
energiereiche strahlung frei so genannte
flyers diese entstehen durch die
wechselwirkung von solaren plasma mit
magnetischen feldlinien erst kürzlich
hatten wir ja hier bei klicks und
science fiction über eine japanische
studie berichtet neben nachkommen
superflex nicht nur bei jungen sterne
vor stattdessen ist dieses phänomen auch
bei älteren langsam rotierenden sternen
wieder sondern zu beobachten allerdings
sind die strahlen ausbrüchen dann nicht
ganz so gewaltig aber immer noch
gewaltig genug in diesem zusammenhang
ist auch der folgende fachbegriff
äußerst spannend koronaler massenauswurf
gemeint sind damit die großen mengen an
heißen plasma die bei den gigantischen
eruptionen ins all geschleudert werden
die folgen dieser teilchenwolken können
auch wir hier auf der erde spüren dann
treffen sie auf die erdatmosphäre werden
dadurch nicht nur polarlichter ausgelöst
sondern auch unsere telekommunikation
und stromnetze sind gefährdet doch all
das passiert nicht nur bei der sonne
sondern auch bei anderen sternen das
problem unsere irdischen teleskopen tun
sich aufgrund ihrer räumlichen und
zeitlich begrenzten auflösung schwer
damit solche solaren eruptionen auch bei
anderen sternen so beobachten
ein italienisches astronomie team hat
jetzt aber den riesenstern mit der
bezeichnung hr 90 24 ins visier genommen
und zwar mit dem chandra
weltraumteleskop der nasa
der riesenstern macht seinem namen alle
ehre er hat einen knapp zehnmal größeren
radius als unsere sonne und deren 3
fache masse und tatsächlich
wurden die fachleute finde ich zum
ersten mal überhaupt also dass ein
astronomie team zeuge eines solchen
koronalen massenauswurf bei einem
anderen stern als der sonne wurde die
experten und expertinnen konnten also
einen strahlend ausbruch beobachten der
einen koronalen massenauswurf auf der
sternoberfläche ausgelöst hatte und
dieser rasse genau in blickrichtung des
teleskops so erschien das spektrum des
plasmas gestaucht dazu konstanzer agiere
die an der studie beteiligt war nachdem
fler stieg kaltes plasma mit
temperaturen von nur vier millionen
calvin und geschwindigkeiten von bis zu
100 kilometern pro sekunde erneut vom
stern auf die beobachtungen zeigen im
großen und ganzen dass die bisherigen
annahmen zu stellaren flex korrekt sind
so das fazit der studie plasma ausbrüche
bei großen und aktiven sternen sind im
vergleich zu unserer sonne also deutlich
umfangreicher das zeigt der ausbruch auf
dem riesenstern ganz deutlich
unglaubliche 1,2 milliarden tonnen
plasma wurden dabei ins all geschleudert
zehntausendfach mehr also als bei den
stärksten ausbrüchen unserer sonne
doch die beobachtung des italienischen
forschungsteams bringen auch
erkenntnisse mit sich die überraschend
alles andere als rekordverdächtig zeit
sich nämlich die kinetische energie
dieses aus geschleuderten plasmas laut
der studie lag dies um das 10.000 fache
niedriger als an hand der
hochgerechneten solaren modelle
angenommen eine abweichung also die
nahelegt dass der beschleunigungs
mechanismus bei riesenstern nicht so
effizient ist wie bei der sonne konkret
zeigte das chandra röntgenteleskop
während des flairs charakteristische
verschiebungen im spektrum der strahlung
die von celan plasma ausgehen die
fachleute interpretieren diese
beobachtungen als auf- und abbewegung
des dlan plasmas zunächst wurde eine
blau dann eine rotverschiebung
bestimmter spektrallinien verzeichnet
nachdem der flair zu ende gegangen war
folgte dann wieder eine blau
verschiebung in der studie werden diese
beobachtung folgendermaßen interpretiert
die ersten beiden doppel verschiebungen
verraten uns dass heißes strahlen zu
beginn des flairs aufwärts steigt und
dann zurück in die cronos fähre fiel
nach angaben des astronomie teams ist
die sehr ähnliche mit der bewegung des
solaren plasmas entlang der
magnetfeldlinien bei einem flair der
soll
bei der eruption am riesenstern hr 90 24
konnten folgende zahlen erhoben werden
das plasma bewegte sich mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 400 kilometern pro
sekunde an den magnetstreifen entlang
und hatte dabei eine temperatur von bis
zu 25 millionen calvin das italienische
forschungsteam feiert diese weltweite
premiere sehr denn ihre beobachtungen
helfen fachleuten weltweit ihre modelle
bezüglich solcher eruptionen bei fremden
sternen anzupassen und zu verbessern zur
sonne liegt ja gerade die packers solar
probt der nasa überhaupt zu verstehen
warum die gase so heiß sind
während die sonnenoberfläche dagegen
ziemlich kühl ist auf dem mond waren wir
dagegen schon mit zahlreichen sonden und
auch menschen am 20 juli berichten wir
zwölf stunden lang quasi live von der
mondlandung vor 50 jahren die
astronauten gerhard thiel und reinhold
jeweils haben wir vorher intensiv
befragt und begleiten die landung mit
ihren sehr spannenden antworten
das ganze basiert sekunden genau 50
jahre später zahlreiche wissenschafts
youtuber wie astor comics tv raumzeit
block der zukunft breaking lab der
medizinstudent doktor watson und neugier
zone sind mit dabei wenn er nichts
verpassen wollt dann klickt hier
und merkt euch den stream vor um 21 uhr
am samstag den 20
juli geht es los bis dann bleibt dran